and if you tried to mail me to my  politics Peter Pan figures out whether  I'm a right wing or left wing or well  I'll tell you straight  more than abstractions and institutions  I will always rely on people right you  know to 11  perhaps uncomfortable for you I remember  back in the 60s my line was if you come  upon a mob you must join and that kind  of radical commitment to free them is  going to be necessary to dismantle and  so the new culture I think is it is a  dispersed about virtual culture on the  internet that is not product oriented  its aesthetics and the best ideas and  but we all have to stop being consuming  we have to redefine really who we are  it's a much more courageous role